yo I got to ask you you're a big alien
guy and recently things have gotten like
it feels like for whatever reason the
last like 12 to 18 months they keep kind
of this like sprinkling little like
breadcrumbs preparing us for the
inevitable in my opinion mhm um you know
whether it's the uh that hearing with
that dude who blew the you know he
pretty much said that we're in
possession of uh Alien aircraft or
whatever the hell and then there's the
Mexican uh two I don't know I don't know
how legit that one was I believe that
[__] I believe it too I believe it um I
mean look if you go back like maybe
seven or eight years ago there was that
guy who was in the Canadian Parliament
talking about it um but yeah man what
like this [__] is crazy like when you
saw the Mexican aliens like what were
your thoughts cuz they really rolled
them out like an official Mexican
government like no that shit's official
here's the problem with the world we've
been lied to and [__] with for so long
that every single time someone posts
something it's just memes and and people
just it turns into social media jokes it
and and that's what they want yeah they
don't want us to think like yo there's a
there's a bigger purpose out there
there's something that we totally don't
even know about there's not there's
something that maybe higher people in
our in our civilization actually
communicate with and get game from if
you look how fast the world grew went
from [__] riding horses to whips and
iPhones and [__] for in a small amount
of time that's coming from somewhere
some Junius just wake up and like I
could [__] make it to you could boom
boom nah we're getting game from
somewhere right and so I believe that
[__] I also believe they they're never
going to tell us what's real they're
probably just trying to prepare us for
some kind of [__] agenda but there's
a lot of Truth in some of that [__]
as well so I if if it's me talking I
know there's a bigger purpose out here
the gut feeling I got that day to go
find a coner doctor bro what the [__]
like right that was bigger than just
like me thinking that I should get a
private doctor there's no reason why on
that day I even felt that in here and
your gut your second brain right um I've
been watching like a lot of near-death
experience stuff because obviously I had
a near-death experience in my opinion I
didn't just die and wake up but like I
came close to it so and watching all
that stuff I just understand there's
bigger purpose as as conscious as like
the Universe goes and so I believe that
little alien was real I believe that
Mexico was the first ones to actually so
something they've been holding I feel
like all these civilizations they're
uncovering like in U and you know in the
jungles and [__] all these different
pyramids we seing man a no humans built
that [__] Bro [__] out of here bro yeah
it's crazy and it's crazy too that like
some of them are so they they match up
other pyramids that are so far apart
well they align with the Stars perfectly
they're all they're all like in
strategic ass you know places in the
world that like will line up with like
the universe perfectly and I I mean
whatever also I know that humans have
dumbed down hard since back in the day
like and that's what they want like they
put so much [__] in propaganda and
they've created the word like conspiracy
theories and and all that stuff so that
way that things that are real like look
at all the people in my seen UFOs back
in the days it made them seem like
[__] Looney dude for sure I mean I
think of like just like if you were to
go back 20 years and if some of this
news would have broke how big of a deal
it' be compared to now and now it's like
no one cares cuz we're so wrapped up in
whatever [__] they're worried about
like how to make the next dollar or
who's [__] cheated on who or [__]
what Kim Kardashian is
doing yeah they're worried about some
[__] that's like yo my man they just
showed an alien from a thous alien
there's a thousand years ago it proves
we're not alone that little [__]
look real [__] and like they're happy
seeing them comments right now the thing
is is like I think once people really
like have to realize there'll be a
moment where they have to really like be
like oh it kind of like it you know for
me I know it's going to make a lot of
people who grew up super religious who
grew up believing certain things it's
going to kind of poke a lot of random
holes in their besides all that have you
ever seen Judah and the black Messiah
yeah all right like look how the
government did them bro look how they
did the Panthers right 100% like bro
they will do things to [__] you off
right like I I'm not going to say no
names I don't want to no smoke with
nobody but I think there's people in our
in our culture right now that caus a lot
of trouble on the on the internet and
with other celebrities I believe they're
working for the CIA that's that's my
honest opinion I'm like yo there's no
way this guy is constantly trying to
Temp people and throw people off their
game and get them to say or do other
things that might put them in jail it's
been their agenda against minorities for
a long time it's crazy I think like
there is some sort of like and and like
you said that word conspiracy theorist
has gotten um it's gotten to the point
where
like you can't question anything without
being called crazy D they have fact
Checkers dog well and to me it's like
you know I remember when conspiracy
theories were like 9/11 and you'd be
like oh you know let me look into this
but now it's like if if you question
anything they put you in that box like I
look at um you know RFK Jr who's
somebody who I I I think is dope you
know I watched his interviews and I
don't think he's said anything crazy you
know what I mean I just think he's just
a curious dude who wants to question
[__] but they are
so they just put them in that box and
then people who don't do the the work or
the like my mom like I told my mom I was
like hey I [__] with RFK and she was
like he's a [__] C he's crazy and I
was like have you ever heard him speak
like he's asking he's at least
addressing real world issues he's
addressing the fact that like multiple
corporations really run everything like
which is crazy which should be the
number one thing everyone should be
worried about that's a concern Monopoly
sucks yeah Vanguard and black rock and
State Street are like kind of running
your entire life and no one's talking
about it but but but that also might be
the reason why he's he's getting boxed
out you know I I mean he's the only
presidential candidate that doesn't have
secret service at his disposal and they
and someone tried to just run up on yeah
so you know the world is full of hidden
agendas the more older you get the more
money you touch the more [__] you
deal with like the [__] I'm dealing with
with these lawsuits and Powerful groups
and big money guys you realize that yo
this shit's real dog like it's it's
different for yeah it's different it's
definitely different uh you mentioned
having 49 albums I always say this uh
when we talk about just
consistency as a MC as a rapper as a
artist I feel like you're one of the
most consistent guys in the game you've
always been
extremely I mean no matter what was
going on in your life you you always
have the time to you know hone in and
create and make an album or collab with
an artist to make a project um for you
uh like you know obviously it's a
passion thing but like for whatever
reason does it still bother you that
maybe you don't get the acknowledgement
or the accolades or the flowers as a as
a rapper that you do for all the other
[__] n because I knew if I put 100%
energy behind music it probably be a lot
bigger right and I argue with my DJ you
know Teflon and this two are about
changing our setup and trying new things
and I just told him I said bro it's a
bandwidth issue at this point like I'm
running cookies clothing I'm running
cookies a Wei business I'm running Vibes
papers I'm running you know this
compound and our media you know out
company that we're trying to build and I
only have so much time for music I told
him music is my therapy bro like I don't
really look at like it's my business if
I treat it more like a business I
probably make way more money I probably
get way more respect I've had people
like two chains be like bro like why
don't you be like
our like Mexican version of Rick Ross
like you got that talk you got that
respect like people [__] with you but
you're not putting enough respect on
like your image and the way I'm like bro
I'm just a real dude bro I don't really
be tripping off like really trying to
build myself as this big old as a facade
if you like you're not a character no I
just feel like music is a good it's a
good therapy for me it's a challenge for
me to still try to stay relevant after
all this time it's a it's a way for me
like to be creative outside of like all
this other stuff I have fun doing it but
I don't treat like my number one
priority I feel like if I did I could be
like a French Montana or something like
that right like I could be looked at as
like a bigger artist right I could wear
jewelry every day and glasses and be
fitted up but like I'm comfortable in
this sweatshit right now I'm rich as
[__] I don't need to show it
right like for what like my new flex is
not the flex I got a pair of earrings on
but I'm not woring my you know 20
different rings I'm not wearing big old
chains or I'm not really worried about
my outfit so much I don't give a [__]
all the billionaires I meet look like
[__] bums they pull up looking real
humble and some dressed down ass [__]
and that's how that's what I want to be
like at this point like bro if you seen
the whip I'm driving in right now I gave
the mayback truck back I'm like bro [__]
all this flashy [__] I got it there's
the world knows I got it so why why even
try to prove it anymore